I can probably tell you some things that
I'm not going to hide an see with the
star yeah we got to make good with ABC
gland I make good with ABC don't do this
to me Kaitlyn Bristowe staying tight
lipped about bachelorette secrets after
calling out bachelor boss Mike Fleiss
for making her turn down Dancing with
the Stars even though he's let multiple
bachelors do the show if they came to
you tomorrow and said next season here
you go would you be down for it
dancing is honestly it's a passion of
mine I never I've never done ballroom
dancing so that would be very new to me
um but yeah cuz I think Sean and I are
in such a good place to that it wouldn't
be like we're jumping the gun and
getting into another show I think he'd
be so supportive and I think it'd be fun
but I also don't think they'll do that
but you didn't make the prediction on
the podcast that you think Rachel will
do Dancing with the Stars after her
season I do I think that because I
stirred up a little bit of controversy
and it got some backlash towards whoever
um I think for sure she'll go invent a
do Dancing with the Stars now just so
they can be like see no no like yeah we
do for the bachelorettes do yeah see we
just did it
eg caught up with Kaitlyn at the latest
taping of her podcast one show off the
vine with two very special guests Heidi
Montag and Spencer Pratt why can't I
binge watch the hills I just feel like
yeah you're number one on iTunes store
you should be doing thinking more
productive
not bad for like my third guest the
first two I'm like I'll get my fiance
then I'll get my best friend and then I
just was like and I'll get Spencer and
Heidi the whole thing with my podcast is
I just like hanging out with people and
drinking wine and just having
conversation and being very unfiltered I
wish I could swear on the podcast but
I'm gonna you know I'm going to try and
not so this one it was basically we
talked a little bit about the hills
about reality TV The Bachelorette
their relationship how it's evolved into
what it is today how they've made it
work and what else we talked about a
snapchat
you